hey guys welcome to another mkbhd video
here we have the blue snowball which i
like to call the snowballer because it's
easily the best usb microphone in this
budget as you might remember i've said
that in a previous video anyway this
video is actually a giveaway video
sponsored by blue so just give this
video a thumbs up and leave a comment of
the color blue snowball you'd like to
win there are three colors and one
random comment will be picked to win
their own blue snowball in their color
of choice directly from blue so if you
are already familiar with the snowball
here's a basic rundown it's a plug and
play usb microphone designed for those
who want affordable really high quality
audio this will blow just about any
built-in microphone and a laptop right
out the water around the back of the mic
you can see that you have a switch
between three built-in patterns cardioid
a 10 decibel padded cardioid and
omnidirectional now while people getting
this mic might not need all these bells
and whistles it's a great place to start
and start learning how these things work
this mic also comes with a pretty sweet
little plastic tripod stand that's
actually surprisingly versatile pretty
nimble i didn't think it would be enough
for me but it actually works just fine
on my desk and lets me use it at a
number of angles to suit me best and the
mic is also light light enough that you
don't need to buy a better stand to use
it this one will seriously do just fine
so i think you get the point this mic is
definitely worth buying even if you
don't win one from your comment today
especially if you're looking for a
professional sounding audio on a tight
budget
so what you're listening to right now is
unedited audio from the blue snowball
right away this is just straight from
the usb microphone plug and play no
enhancements whatsoever and as you can
hear for the price or even for any usb
microphone this sounds really good so i
have no problem with using this for
youtube and you can probably tell why i
rated this as one of my highest
microphones available for any sort of
youtube video producer someone who's
beginning so overall what would i rate
this microphone well definitely for
sound quality it could be better but
then again this is better than most
other usb microphones so i'm going to go
ahead and give this a 7 out of 10 for
audio quality bow construction like i
mentioned in the video is mostly plastic
but it's fantastic plastic there's no
problems with it seven and a half out of
ten and for ease of use this this is
hands down one of the easiest
microphones to use 10 out of 10
wonderful job from blue there and
overall i give this microphone an eight
or an eight and a half this is a great
mic for beginners on youtube and again
if you want to win one make sure you
leave a thumbs up on this video and
leave a comment of one of the three
colors available that you can win
directly from blue that's basically it
guys thanks for watching and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you